salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche et c'est le jour des explications
mais également de la fête des mères donc bonne fête à toutes les mamans qui regardent cette vidéo
et plus particulièrement à la mienne
bonne fête maman ! en fait c'est un piège que je viens de tendre à ma mère
si jamais elle ne me répond pas sur le fait que je lui ai souhaité bonne fête dans cette vidéo
alors je saurais qu'elle ne les regarde pas toutes
et je l'oblige à les regarder
en ce jour particulier je me suis dit que ça en valait le coup de faire des choses un petit peu particulière
par exemple j'ai mis une chemise au lieu d'un T-short
comme ça vous n'allez pas me dire qu'il n'est pas repassé
Aujourd'hui, je vous apprends un tour que vous allez pouvoir faire à votre mère aujourd'hui
Alors forcément vous pourrez toujours le faire à quelqu'un d'autre ou le réadapter
mais j'ai vraiment pensé pour que ce soit un tour spécial fête des mères
que vous puissiez faire facilement chez vous avec pas grand-chose
et qui s'apprenne vite
alors c'est pas un tour de mentalisme c'est un tour de magie
et comme ça, quels que soient vos moyens, votre âge, le temps que vous avez eu pour cette fête des mères
vous pouvez au moins offrir ce tour là à votre mère
je vais vous faire le tour pour vous faire voir ce que ça donne
vous prenez un jeu de carte dans vos mains et vous allez le confier à votre mère
donc je vais vous dire à quel moment il faut lui passer le jeu
donc voilà, vous lui dites que vous avez un tour à lui faire pour son anniversaire
et vous lui dites : voilà maman dans quelques secondes tu vas prendre le jeu
et tu vas donner les cartes en deux tas, comme ça
Vous lui tendez le jeu, elle le prend et vous continuez de  lui expliquer
qu'elle dépose les cartes comme elle veut, sur les tas qu'elle veut
Elle peut en mettre plusieurs ici, un peu moins là...
même des gros paquets, un petit peu là, elle alterne un petit peu comme elle veut
et elle donne tout le jeu comme ça
Pour ceux qui se posent la question, peu importe si le jeu est complet ou pas
Afin que tout le monde puisse réaliser le tour, j'ai pensé à ça aussi
Une fois que la distribution est terminé, en réalité c'est assez rapide à faire
Vous lui dîtes :  voilà ce qui passe, tu vas prendre le 1 er tas
Et tu vas le séparer en deux comme tout à l'heure, en en mettant une à gauche, une à droite
une à gauche, une à droite, une à gauche, une à droite, jusqu'à ce que
il n'y en ai plus
mais ce coup-ci tu fais bien carte par carte
Comme il n'y a pas beaucoup de cartes, ça va
Ce qui donne à peu près , je vous accélèrerai la vidéo
pendant ce temps là vous pouvez  vous peut-être faire l'autre paquet
Puisqu'il faudra le faire également sur l'autre paquet
Ou alors vous lui demandez de faire la même chose avec l'autre paquet
Deux tas supplémentaires, en suivant la même règle
On a au final 4 tas qu'a fait votre mère
vous lui rappelez : voilà t'as donné les cartes comme tu voulais au départ
T'en a mis plus d'un côté, plus de l'autre...
Tout était complétement aléatoire
Et pourtant, si je retourne la 1 ère carte de chaque paquet
Il y a marqué : Bonne fête des mères
tadaaaa
Bonne.....Fête des ..... Mères
Et maintenant, je vous explique comment ce tour fonctionne
Alors au départ j'ai pris 4 cartes
Sur lesquelles j'ai collé un petit post-it
J'ai même scotché pour écrire le message que je voulais faire passer
J'aurais aussi pu prendre des cartes blanches
Mais comme c'est pas commun, tout le monde en a pas
Mais si vous avez des cartes a dos rouge ou bleu et blanches de l'autre côté
Vous pouvez écrire votre message directement dessus
Et si vous n'avez pas de post-it ou de truc comme ça vous pouvez écrire directement sur les 4 as
Puisqu'il y a de la place
Pour le faire moi, ça se voit pas, mais j'avais pris les 4 dames
Donc vous réalisez ça comme vous voulez
On va faire maintenant ce qu'on apelle un montage du jeu
Vous prenez la 1 ère carte donc la "bonne", vous la mettez dos en l'air dans vos mains
Ensuite vous prenez la 3 ème carte, donc la "mères"
Vous la mettez dans vos mains
Vous prenez la 2 ème carte, donc la "fête des "
Vous la mettez face en bas dans vos mains
Et enfin la dernière carte
Au dessus
Et vous placez l'ensemble, cet ensemble des 4 cartes
Sur le paquet
Ce qui vous donne un paquet face en bas avec un nombre de cartes
Alors..... que le jeu soit complet ou pas
Et les dernière cartes qui sont sur le dessus sont bien : bonne
Mère, fête des
Et ma carte..... Et ma carte un peu décorée
C'est une décoration pourrie
En même temps, si vous regardez la vidéo sur les dessins
Ce n'est pas surprenant
A partir de là , le tour est quasiment fini
Au tout départ, moi j'ai fait un mélange, c'est un faux mélange français
S'il y a des magiciens qui regardent voilà j'ai juste fait un faux mélange français
D'ailleurs s'il y a des magiciens qui regardent moi j'aurais un petit truc pour vous
A la fin de la vidéo
C'est à dire après l'image de fin
Sinon, vous sortez juste le jeu de l'étui
et vous dites, voilà ce qu'on va faire, on va
faire un tour
Pour lui faire voir l'exemple, vous posez les cartes comme ceci
En alternant gauche-droite, gauche-droite
les 4 premières cartes, donc
Les 4 cartes de votre message
On va placer d'un côté les deux premières cartes du message
Et d'un côté les deux deuxièmes
C'est pour ça qu'on les avait alternés
Ensuite effectivement votre mère fait vraiment ce qu'elle veut
Elle peut mettre le nombre de cartes qu'elle veut de chaque côté, peu importe
Quand bien même elle mettrait pas tout le jeu
ça n'aurait aucune espèce d' importance
Vous lui demandez de reprendre les paquets et de diviser carte par carte
là c'est important, carte par carte
Les deux dernières cartes seront forcément les deux premières carte du message
Et évidemment pareil pour l'autre paquet
J'espère que ce petit tour adapté à la fête des mères vous aura plus
Evidemment vous pouvez le garder pour plus tard
comme une idée
Pour faire apparaître autre chose, un autre message
Ou même ne pas mettre de message et faire sorti les 4 as
comme ça, par quelqu'un
Vous voyez ce que je veux dire, pensez à le réadapter
à votre sauce, comme vous voulez
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo spécial fête des mères
Si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en laissant un petit pouce
en l'air
Vous pouvez également cliquer la haut pour vous abonner à la chaîne
car le mental vlog c'est 1 vidéo par jour pendant 1 an
donc rendez vous demain à 17h ciao
Je vous donne une idée pour un tour un petit peu similaire je ne vous l'explique pas
Si vous avez les bases en magie vous suivrez vous comprendrez
les techniques employées
c'est vraiment pour vous donnez une idée supplémentaire